It's weird, right?
The humans' obsession with our poop?
I mean, just look at the lengths they've gone to harvest this stuff.
Have you ever noticed how excited they get when the dog goes number two?
What a good boy.
That's my baby.
All we know for certain is that our feces must be very valuable.
Why else would they have invented this?
This crazy, high-tech poop-harvesting machine.
Look at this thing.
I don't even remember what my poo smells like anymore.
It's like a part of me doesn't exist.
Every few weeks a fresh tray of crystals automatically shows up...
...to keep the whole system running.
They've built an entire infrastructure to whisk our poo off...
...to an undisclosed location in an armored tank.
But have you ever stopped to ask yourself why.
Open your eyes, people.
They're using us for our poo.